from the director he just wants to watch
the world go bum and the studio that
enables them comes the dumbest most
incoherent Transformers movie yet which
is really saying something did he just
punch a guy with a car transformers age
of extinction prepare for a total
reinvention of the franchise with an
all-new cast all-new villains and cool
new allies only to end up with the same
over long peace ocean where we once
again have no
idea what
happening
hey if michael bacon ryu shots we can
reuse transformers jokes Shia LaBeouf is
gone and neither you nor bumblebee know
Optimus Prime will care where he went
instead settle it with Boston native
Texan Cade Yeager a man fighting against
all odds to sound intelligent that as a
super simplex theater projector is very
rare who taught you how to solder a
circuit me that's what I do
oh and he's all doing it better I know
you have a conscience because you're an
inventor like me I'm so gonna patent
this some things should never be
invented and that's what great Avengers
do I'm an inventor this could be a
game-changer for me if I can apply that
technology to my inventions we never
have to worry about money again you're
an inventor we get it in a franchise
that's known for objectifying hot young
women prepare for a new low as they make
the movies hot chick and underage girl
sweetheart yes Schwartz shrinking by the
second make her boyfriend illegal adult
and literally stop the movie to explain
why it's okay for them to pork the
17-year old girl
how old are you 20 she's a minor or
protected by the Romeo and Juliet laws
we dated for a little while I was a
sophomore and he was a senior it's fine
no it's not fine we've got a
pre-existing juvenile foundational
relationship statute to 7-0 4-3 what if
only they put as much time into
justifying the plot as they did for
having sex with a minor
the Transformers are back and there is
over these movies as we are this isn't a
fight let's go see ya goodbye especially
Optimus Prime we're done defending the
humans Autobots we're done watch as they
bumble their way through another Michael
Bay crap fest so lazily produced he
didn't bother to fix these green screen
monitors as scenes go from day to night
today again and let the Sears Tower up
in the background of Hong Kong so get
ready for another sequel that you hoped
would be better but instead shove the
same exact thing down you're gullible
throats featuring even more unrealistic
explosions going off around unfunny
comic relief during a never-ending
sunset near an American flag
hey guys why is the rest of the trailer
written in Chinese you go peon - ooh
[ __ ] yo hey
say ho well doesn't seem true guardian
Iguchi dreaming do CLI Wilmington
cellphone piercing Dingaan synthetic
heroin routed signatures Iran Kuwait on
Guam in Sipan yo what will add rant over
in the chin
oh man I can't come microbio dormitory
Cho Seon ho means he managed hunting zu
ho - Angela dollar drunk war that I do
when I enter and colgado tuned wrong way
John Boehner UN cadeau gelatine Tom
Daschle second can come on quarreling
Carrera Duomo do she'll do your qualia
we got a call the central government for
help English in very low meadow is in
Canton mi cabeza shabbat see Patrick I
see do with Hannah salami
Trudeau Daquan Amana yelling central
unit ah hey yo India more torture sayin
intensity ginger Sparkle such a fool
otally one hi Mei foreign KO taan
potential new home and a new July aqua
conscience Sheikh Ali aah Wade olya
Domini palm food hub by way PG Oh Eva hi
Hong Sharma Poochie Paul Malini
Lamborghini honk our one true love
slicin
hey Johnny sure : pooja deep outro
Kyrie laka home knowing no I just got
picked up already
by way Quito your court Oh
Martha long you like music
the poor Ely sure honey mmm yes I'm
single sue quietly Dom a leader drunk or
Dean - Jorge oh come on the tuition that
should show shall open Joey
we are tied today Soho don't go and say
my name is Optimus Prime and I send this
message to all of humanity
please subscribe I just went myself Luca
Chaka ooga ooga oogachaka that wizard
came from the moon
jiggly cupcake muffins hey screen
junkies did you know that the epic movie
voice of honest trailers has his own
YouTube channel click here to subscribe
for epic movie reviews impressions
gameplay parodies and stuff this guy's
channel sounds awesome